je le connais
public
s'il vous plaît ce qu'on peut me
renvoyer le numéro de l'heureux gagnant
est on part de rien raconte par
téléphone
on a ce soir dans notre émission merci
de nous rejoindre à 19h15 dans when we
sur l'arbre cette nouvelle émission il
vous est proposé sur s'est vite où est
la mienne ce soir une fois de plus
l'amour un téléphone une personne c'est
un concept sa faute déposera
pas qu'on appelle à
un téléphone une personne amoureuse
comme disais barbaste jean mas
d'ailleurs est en train de manger les
figo lui en train de nous regarder
pourquoi
daniel la personne je vais l'appeler
chauffe c'est à toi de me dire
que je l'appelle si tu veux que tout
simplement je continue à faire des deux
micros t4
alors façon oui josé daniel
terre battue que je dise pas la vérité
[Rires]
l'audition je te fait trois propositions
de ce que je vais lui dire accord
première proposition petit à bonjour
monsieur je ne donnerai pas son prénom
je suis l'envoyé de l'amour le message
et de l'amour il ya une personne ici sur
mon plateau
qui a eu un gros gros coup de coeur pour
vous elle souhaiterait vous parlez vous
le dire c'est une téléspectatrice si
vous êtes ça c'est la réalité pas une
solution solution bée solution mais
notion téléspecteurs puisqu'elle le
voilà la solution b bonjour monsieur je
suis et cyril hanouna je décline tout de
suite mon identité je suis avec daniel
moreau daniel moreau chroniqueuse de mon
émission non ça vaut mieux pas tout de
suite j'ai eu un flash pourquoi
plus tôt
voilà problème c'est que nature si vous
êtes un journaliste et vous êtes un
homme politique
très respectée
ici
une chroniqueuse qui à lachenaie kung fu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
réponse mais là c'est agaçant au bâton
c'est la méritait toujours la vérité and
there is armée mais la baisse est mon
nom on la laisse réfléchir s'il vous
plaît on la laisse réfléchir à ce qu'on
réfléchisse si je voulais un beau jour
dans un instant chez vous
pouvez la apparaître le visage
on verra apparaître le visage
c'est lui
toute la france attend
visage de cet homme ohlala aimer à
perdre la raison et met à le savoir que
dire à cela mais là c'est mon va-tout et
mais
par daniel
vit encore en cours
dans un instant nous appellerons cette
personne qui va s'afficher ici au nom
accès on saura si pour la vie ces
deux-là
crâne vivront là comme un crabe au bord
de l'eau assez génial british à la
chérie jetons destin se joue dans
quelques instants laniel n'est pas venu
vous dire un dernier mot à nos
téléspectateurs
avant de faire ce long voyage que tout
le monde a
gagné le monde
dont la culotte été fermée à double tour
civique ou une liste de mots interdits
culotte chaudière
est ce que baraque à frites se passe à
wall des fans quelques mots comme ça
interdit pendant les cinq premiers
j'aime daniel moreau est amoureuse voilà
daniel moreau c'est mon cas donc c'est
en
[Rires]
tellement émue ces personnes et que
je m'adapte itv spécial qui vous à
compter des millions
il fait comme si c'est un coeur qui
battait était persuadé que c'était son
coeur qu'elle entendait on va dire que
daniel moreau qui a touché 7 quitte la
diane moreau chavire mais elle chavire
peut-être là non elle va salir et
peut-être de bonheur dans un instant
quand la personne que nous aurons au
bout du fil chante dira oui tu es
maintenant y'a aucune chaîne jouera
jamais votre hauteur vous êtes un dieu
vous êtes un chai pas vous feriez vous
feriez des miracles
si je dois payer je le ferai
je rigole
de questions
et trouver les mots déjà dans votre tête
vous avez vous des revenants suzanne
hommes d'impro je vais tout de suite
sentir au bonjour à l'eau c'est un
feeling d'abord je dois demeurer comme
ça vous dit un halo salon
c'est diego aurait donc non et après je
vois ce que c'est ma dernière chance
cyril aller non ça c'est votre dernière
chance ne gâchez pas ça s'en va tout
daniel moreau je suis son va tout et
bien écoutez quand on voit la gueule du
bateau
on a envie de venir daniel vous allez au
devant de grandes déconvenues
daniel on va voir apparaître au non non
c'est pas ça sur mon écran je peux pas
le visage moi je regarde cet homme
qui est aimé
par cette personne non mais j'adore
daniel n'est pas bien regardé amoureux
est ce que tu veux on est obligé de
mettre 60 des dalles jouer mais je
regarde derrière eux
pourquoi pourquoi tu ne veux pas
regarder fois ci que ça va trop
impressionné
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ça n'est pas
castaldi
[Applaudissements]
elle est vraiment noise tania syrie
c'est vrai que je t'ai jamais vu comme
ça ah non mais je me reconnecte est
commun c'était comme un sens un motorola
qui dit moi a
lancé un téléphone non mais c'est vrai
quand le vibreur d'amener des comme ça
daniel
je vais encore te laisser réfléchir
parce que je sens que ta décision est
difficile
tu sais je n'ai pas de safer dans
l'émission
j'ai aussi des sujets à traiter alors
bien sûr tu as un sujet important dans
la galaxie des pmp
c'est génial ça m'a un peu de radio cité
rien et ça c'était mon père mon
saint cyrille que le bien-être des
chroniqueurs compte beaucoup pour voir
exactement et elle est vraiment mais
j'ai peur alors je vous dis je ne veux
pas être un oiseau de mauvaise augure
ouais c'est ça j'ai peur que si
derrière on a une mauvaise réponse ils
sont tous en fait attention là on n'a
pas de réponse du tout il s'est même pas
qu'elle existe
car qu'est ce qui se passe on
fera un énorme prime
[Applaudissements]
ça
sa mission est bien armé 12 ans l'amour
serait énorme là on est dans une autre
dimension je pourrais pas danser je
pourrais rien faire et n'y allèrent pour
l'instant demande pas de danse et je
demande juste d'aimer
sa savane yale sur cette séquence tu n'a
besoin que d'une chose de ton coeur et
oui j'ai eu peur mon coeur va battre
après ça c'est ton coeur va battre de
plus en plus en plus fort même temps
peut-être pour
j'espère ne pas lâcher
écoutez moi je il a battu 67 ans
on a vu des accidents je suis désolé m
20 ans daniel où commence et où s'arrête
enfin prime
avec les meilleures séquences de ça
chaque base
comment le départ
ça tu leur as moreau n'est pas mort
ah bon pour rien congrès va lui et vous
mes chances à 0
je rigole ça va c'est pour la détendre
on sait s'il est célibataire alors que
je sais c'est un jeu pas ne savent pas
l'accès des bleus c'est pas sûr mais
voilà estimant qu'on peut relever mais
c'est quelqu'un qui ne sait pas
l'existant daniel sait pas qu'elle aime
ou marié peut-être marié sermon le
parent de la part de la manquez pas leur
bagnole qu'est ce que je fais il faut
lever
jusqu'à noël si vous me dites vous avez
trois mois me dire mais go go go way
beaucoup
et on go go go go go go go go go
[Applaudissements]
le
reste
j'ai décidé de garder l'anonymat
j'essaie de garder l'anonymat ont ce
coup de fil
à son vieux pardessus et
j'en donnais l'hiver l'été badiane mais
c'est vous que c'est bien toi me croirez
pas c'est pas grave tu sais daniel va
peut-être perdre beaucoup plus
qu'est-ce qui me restera pas qu'est-ce
qui traitera des lettrés ce sera moi
avec un grand m
le lot de consolation
allez on va prendre
daniel est ce que tu veux que son visage
apparaissent oui bah oui derrière match
[Applaudissements]
mais la télé tous les jours
personnage public
on attend de la voirie sagement ya la
danse on se prépare dans ce qui se
prépare et contemporain ouais c'est
génial c'est un service dit quelque
chose avec son corps ne laissait de
faire c'est génial phalène fait
apparaître
l'heureuse élue fournier une belle photo
sony que les français
à
vingt clubs excusez moi si on attendait
pas dit ça
t'imagines le plus
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
maintenant c'est plus de bob l'épongé
sawicki de sens
c'est un grand monsieur georges fenech
trigui sanaa se doit d'être des gens
comme il est magnifique sanaa
midtjylland très bon il ya il est né en
tunisie
non ouais je l'adoré
alors sachez qu'on on l'a invité
plusieurs fois dans l'émission et à
chaque fois le pot voilà on a dû
l'annuler parce qu'en fait on n'a pas
fait le sujet
je vous adore serre et moi je l'adoré
vous lui aussi n'en veut pas du tout et
vous adore mais vraiment je l'adorent et
je le trouve très beau ouais je trouve
que c'est un excellent choix il est beau
et intelligent à la plus dans la version
vous allez me dire qu'est ce qui va
[ __ ] dans cette galère
je ne m'étends l'atmosphère
non mais c'est bien le vendre coiffard
oui
je vais te dire
des lunettes à castres
c'est parti c'est vous qui paraît jeudi
à se faire l'heure est à l'amour
j'appelle et vers 7h et georges fenech
un an georges fenech qui ne s'est pas
qu'aujourd'hui
un petit bonhomme
d'un petit bonhomme le messager de la
mort la frappe est
c'est parti
charest flanqué d'un judas pour regarder
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il est
tellement belle voix
allô
bonjour monsieur fenech
bonjour excusez moi de vous déranger
c'est cyril hanouna
qui
vous dérange
pas du tout
georges je suis en direct je viens de
dire que j'étais fan de vous je vous
adorez je vous trouve qu'en plus d'être
mis en tunisie ok à tunis donc vraiment
à choucha sous c'est exactement à sousse
c'est vrai donc qu'on a on a beaucoup de
points communs
georges je vous appelle pour ça pour
vous dire je vous aime énormément et que
je voulais m'excuser parce qu'à chaque
fois vous avez failli venir dans
l'émission est à chaque fois comme un
abruti
ggg voilages et j'ai fait des sujets qui
sont durs qui ont duré trop longtemps
donc voilà vous avez le bonjour de tout
le monde on est en direct et genre je
vous appelle parce que vous ne me
laissait pas indifférent par votre talon
mais il y a parmi nos équipes et parmi
nos chroniqueuse au nom quelqu'un qui
est tombé éperdument amoureuse de vous
c'est l'amour qui frappe à votre porte
ça vous fait rien
georges déjà merci merci le prendre
comme ça
georges la personne est vraiment folle
amoureuse de vous et nous parle de vous
depuis deux jours
elle se couche en pensant à vous elle se
réveille en pensant à vous
dans l'émission et ne pensent qu'à vous
georges aujourd'hui je suis face à un
problème
majeur cette personne voudrais vous dire
un mot emmerdes c'est danielle moores ou
non
voyez vous c'est
[Applaudissements]
mais bien sûr je crois bien qu'ils aient
daniel moreau qui est une chroniqueuse
talentueuse je connais son parcours de
journaliste mais assure georges vous
êtes extraordinaire déjà je l'avais
illuminer son visage et les femmes c'est
tout georges leur genre vous êtes et
georges est très bon ce que géniteur
franchement c'est vrai mais il a tout
pour lui donc forcément voilà c'est
normal que vous craquez pour l'une
daniel est ce que vous avez un mot à
dire à jean je vais vous le passez aux
noms mais jorge a été extrêmement sympa
et je peux vous dire que sur la route de
l'amour on n'est pas encore au péage
mende a pris la première boîte elle
s'avoue la passion
à l'eau non mais à la
cci l'impression d'être dans un rêve
et non mais excusez moi puisque chez
midinettes camille net et j'ai peur que
vous pensez que c'est une plaisanterie
mais c'est passé voilà c'est vrai je ne
sais pas d'échec vous me faites mais je
peux même pas vous dire mais vous êtes
tellement brillant est tellement beau je
nous ai même pas pensé un jour que je
parlerai avec vous et lâchés en train de
me ridiculiser parce que rossi
devant devant wicked chaudière
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé parce que ça doit être
très gênant pour vous savez aussi pour
moi mais mais je le disais que j'avais
aucune chance de vous croiser de vous
rencontrer que généralement rien tout
composera son va-tout en fait
je vais très très touché
seniors
sinon beaucoup plus
grand plaisir à vous rencontrer mais je
ne suis pas tout seul ma chère
l'argent c'est pas grave daniel aussi un
animal de compagnie
[Applaudissements]
attendez
ce n'est pas tout seul c'est évident
genre c'est évident qu'un homme comme
vous voilà c'est normal vous prie c'est
comme si voilà c'est vrai alors
ce n'est pas un râteau ce n'est pas la
hâte au genre a été extrêmement violent
et vous a dit vous allez vous dirai en
inde air avec
george
george en tout cas voilà merci on vous
adore et sigean sachez le vous est
extraordinaire et vous êtes vraiment
assez vous avez vous avez tous voilà
vous avez tout est ce que je dis quand
on quand on a vu qu'ils étaient sont
celui sur qui elle avait jeté son dévolu
on s'est dit elle doit pas être la seule
eh bien on sait pas tout georges
opposant whatfor continuer ce que vous
faites est juste là vous viendrez nous
voir un jour bien sûr
cher daniel
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal merci
georges est vraiment un amour merci
beaucoup joué merci je vous embrasse
loiret saint amour un amour
cette spirale mais j'en ai marre ils
sont tous très
ce qui est pris n'est plus à prendre non
agnel il est malheureusement prime mais
je trouve qu'il n'ya pas que du négatif
mais c'est bien mais
j'ai pas été mauvais ouais merci ses
rides avant j'ai failli déraper
non mais vraiment sembler la cg et
daniel j'ai une raison j'ai par contre
c'est pas parce que j'aimerais bien mais
je sais pas j'ai entendu avait été noyée
alors vous avez mal il ya un verre dans
la gueule
maintenant liens vers les nominés
gentleman
c'est la glace tu adhères mais moi je
crois tu en train de tomber amoureux lui
ça y est on a mis on avait très que je
m'en porte pas la même pas quel côté
sport daniel saba pas trop non aux
patients et non parce que je rêvais
c'est vrai non je réponds non alors
attentes autour du temps et je vais te
dire on avait ravi je vais te dire il ya
plein de personnes qui étaient avec 10
personnes bah oui oui non mais je veux
pas j'ai pas je veux pas souhaité non
merci je vais te dire le truc qui a
c'est que tu sais parfois salariés c'est
parti
j'ai parfois tu ouvre une porte et tu te
dis pourquoi pas en ouvrir une autre
ouais et deux ports de suite oui c'est
une
grande maison et ma maison à porte
c'est la paire qui disait ça daniel
daniel ma chérie je veux pas que tu sois
triste ben parce que daniel aujourd'hui
on a avancé bah oui tu veux te dire tu
sais ce qui est pire dans l'amour non
fassi le râteau lassé de ne pas savoir
non mais tu sais je vais te dire
certitude la certitude c'est ce qui est
pire aujourd'hui tu sais que le chemin
va être rude le chemin va être long mais
tu restes ou encore paulstra mais il est
peu connu et apprécié
paolo fabien c'est bien sûr ça va ça
roule avant de décoller bien sûr une
voiture
[Applaudissements]